aquí tenemos un retrato extraordinario
este retrato parece parece tan real
parece vivo es natural amo su vestido a
músico llar su moño la pluma me encanta
la manera como ella hace la cortina
hacia un lado como asomándose para ver
algo y es en verdad hermoso parece a
pesar de tener todos estos artefactos
esta complejidad en el vestuario no solo
es natural ella sale ya resalta ella
está llena de energía y curiosidad y se
siente como que en verdad llegas a
conocerla este retrato fue comisionado
por su esposo en la tarde de la
revolución francesa y su nombre es
madame pedregón y este es un retrato por
elisabeth fritzl el programa es muy
interesante porque observa cómo fue
construida esta pintura ella ha tomado
una composición muy sencilla y
tradicional de una mujer sobre un balcón
y la mitad de su retrato una cortina por
un lado y el otro lado abierto también
vemos que se ha creado un sentido de
revelación al mover esa cortina hacia
atrás es como un pequeño teatro
también la construcción de un bello arco
en la derecha inferior y hay unos
cuantos arcos más los arcos de sus
brazos el de su collar el arco de su
sombrero y es el moño rojo ese mono rojo
tan encantador para su saco su saco de
cintura de broma que ha tomado un
elemento formal de esa cortina rota esa
cortina aburrida que vemos en figuras en
retratos y la ha convertido en algo
juguetón en algo alegre algo travieso
está increíble en verdad me encanta me
cautiva creo que es un ejemplo
majestuoso de como un retrato puede ser
traído a la vida puedes hacer que cobre
vida